in Hong Kong police have hired pepper
pellets to disperse crowds of protesters
in the city centre hundreds of riot
police have surrounded the legislature
building and anticipation of protests
the territory's pro-democracy protesters
want to voice their opposition to a bill
criminalizing disrespect for China's
national anthem which lawmakers are
currently debating for more now we're
joined by DW correspondent Phoebe Cong
in Taipei Phoebe
we understand riot police have
surrounded Hong Kong's legislature
building what's happening there today a
controversial national anthem bill will
be tabled in a Hong Kong legislature
today for his second reading so as you
have mentioned the law is going to
affect and prohibiting disrespect to the
Chinese national anthem so this is a
piece of law like already being like
implemented in the mainland China and
now the Hong Kong government is trying
to push for the same set of legislation
in Hong Kong in a bit - to ban such like
this respect and insult and it carries a
maximum of three year imprisonment if
anyone violates the law and from the
past from the perspective of many like
protesters and pro-democracy figures
they think this toast of risk that it
may repress the citizens in in the
further sense that it made like harm the
freedom of expression of the people in
Hong Kong so um people have been calling
for protests today to protest to
demonstrate against this law and the CFC
like police have already the heavily
guarded the whole legislative complex
and in a bid to prevent any large-scale
clashes and protests but people are
still coming out as we observed the
pro-democracy movement in Hong Kong TV
is up in arms about Beijing's plans to
impose new laws particularly a new
security law on the territory can we
expect violent protests like we saw in
Hong Kong
last year it's a difficult question to
answer like because as we see like today
there have been the various cause online
the people urging each other to come out
again to turn out on the streets to
protest on a lot that they disagree with
but we have said like we have seen like
the police have changed her tactics
drastically they got every like entrance
of the metro stations and subway
stations and they stopped and searched a
large amount of people on the streets
like to prevent anyone together and try
to assemble with each other so it's
getting more and more difficult and
challenging or even more risky for
people to gather and protest on the
streets and also like even the fact that
Hong Kong is still implementing a social
distancing rule which prohibits any
gatherings with like people with like
over 8 people so these can be and other
reasons or like excuse for the authority
to crack down on such protests but with
like many frontline protesters they are
still determined to protest
Phebe thank you very much for now that
was DWS PB Kong in Taipei all for now
let's go straight over to Alvin Young
he's a member of Hong Kong's Legislative
Council and leader of the pro-democracy
Civic party thanks for being with us mr.
young where do you stand on the proposed
national anthem law hello Terry
thank you for having me simply speaking
the Democratic camp is united in
opposition to this controversial
national anthem law we see that you do
not regulate people and legalize or
restrict people from respecting a
national anthem or even a country you
earn your respect you do not make law to
make people to respect you ok law on the
national anthem is one thing but Beijing
is preparing to impose a sweeping
national security law on Hong Kong with
far-reaching implications what impact do
you think that will have it undercuts
Hong Kong's legislature it doesn't go
through the Hong Kong legislature in
fact Beijing simply the what impose is
an accurate way to talk about to say
that because Beijing doesn't consult
Hong Kong people they just say you have
to take it and more importantly this
controversial national security law will
undermines Hong Kong's
high degree of autonomy and also the
freedom that guarantees hong kong some
success if Beijing is determined to
exert more control over Hong Kong is
there really anything you can do to stop
it well in practice perhaps is very
difficult to stop Beijing from imposing
such controversial piece of legislation
on Hong Kong but on the other hand Hong
Kong people would not stop fighting we
would not simply compromise or say come
and take it over the past year with
witness thousands and thousands of Hong
Kong people talk to the street in
opposition to the den controversial
extradition the extradition bill and
this year when it comes to national
security people are equally angry about
it and obviously people would take their
chances to voice out and more
importantly Hong Kong is no ordinary
city of China this is an international
financial hub and we are doing
everything we can to tell the rest of
the world so that the rest of the world
would understand and stand with Hong
Kong now we're just seeing some pictures
of some police on the streets clashing
with protesters to some degree we're
hearing that there's a massive police
presence in Hong Kong they're
surrounding Parliament stopping and
searching people even using pepper
pellets how concerned are you about a
total police crackdown in Hong Kong
extremely ah we have according to the
reports there are over 3,500 policemen
on the street on duty today I personally
witnessed countless police officers in
food uniform
Antti right uniforms surrounding the
legislate Legislative Council building
become a this is the people's Parliament
in theory and they are trying to stop
people from getting close to the
Parliament
what sort of part what sort of
government or Parliament sisters so when
they are trying to pass this national
anthem law and try to earn people's
respect
they are basically doing something to
the complete opposite how confident are
you that other countries will come to
Hong Kong's aid given China's importance
on the international stage at the end of
the day is up to each and every country
and their people whadda you would speak
up for Hong Kong this is not only about
interest I know a lot of countries
including Germany have a lot of people
living in Hong Kong
you have your investments here but not
only that Hong Kong has long been a
member of the free world we share the
same values we share the same liberty
and freedom and now when China is trying
to take this away from Hong Kong we
expect the rest of the world will speak
up for us mr. Ewing thank you very much
for talking with us today that was Alvin
Young a member of Hong Kong's
Legislative Council and leader of the
Civic party thank you